Riley Apple oh and all my hip hell I
thought I was bidden I know it was kind
of Awesome oh my goodness the last of us
left behind I played that game ten
months ago and it's still just every
time I think about it I get so excited
because like yes that game is built on
something's things that make the last of
us great and made it our ps3 game of the
year last year but what it does with
gameplay what it does with characters
are so uniquely its own and such an
incredible achievement within that game
that it's just ah it's so it's so good
the relationship between Ellie and Riley
just is one of the most real nuanced
friendships and we only spend like three
hours with those two and like not even
the full time with them together but
you're bumping up not again not just
against the extremes of relationship
that can happen to know the world of the
Last of Us which is a totally effed up
place to live but also the kind of
friendship stuff that's like hey like I
haven't seen in a while there's like a
little bit of distance between us hey
like I'm kind of upset with you like
like oh and this is a little awkward
like there's this such subtlety between
it and then on the flip side of those
negative emotions the tenderness the
friendship like the easy laughter is
just the way it's written the way it's
acted so so incredible and then I think
what really makes it for me is how
gameplay complements that perfectly I
mean this isn't just I'm listening to
dialogue it's I'm choosing to like
stroll around this mall and like read
terrible joke after terrible joke from
this joke book and I can't stop I don't
want to miss it like I don't want to let
AG line of dialogue go unheard I don't
want to let a mask go untried as we're
chasing each other around this Halloween
store it's that and then a few other
moments are just so so special guys are
blood covers the entire playing field oh
nice what is it about a game that you
can complete in you know a day
an afternoon or a long night that makes
it like heads and shoulders above these
and a game that's DLC to boot yeah I
mean you know I think that this really
hits at one of the sort of wonderful and
important things about videogames
is that the care with which these things
are created and the variability the
sheer spectrum of what a game can be is
changing and evolving every year and so
to have a game like Left Behind go up
against a Dragon Age or something like
that is not only like it's not only
legit it's necessary because what they
do is is so unique and so incredible in
their in their own ways that you you
have to look at them that way you have
to treat them with that respect because
what they deliver is just something we
should all be super thankful for